why is this particular
collection of humans we call a nation
a uniquely powerful way to preserve the
freedom of a people to have people rule
themselves
before i say anything on the subject i
should emphasize that i'm not a
rationalist i'm an empiricist and i'm
i'm i'm offering what
uh
what i think is a valid observation of
of human history i i don't have some
kind of deductive framework for proving
that you know that the nation is the
best and empirically we know something
about the way systems of national states
work and about the way empires work and
the way tribal societies work
uh what we don't know is uh you know
is it possible to invent something else
or i mean there's a lot of things we
don't know here
so
with the caveat that i'm i'm making an
empirical observation the basic argument
is
human beings form collectives naturally
loyalty groups
and
for most of human history and prehistory
as far as as as we know human beings
lived in tribal societies tribal
societies or societies um in in in which
there's
um
uh constant friction and constant
warfare uh among very small groups among
among families and clans
and we reach a turning point in human
history with the invention of
large-scale agriculture
which allows the creation of vast wealth
it allows the establishment of standing
armies instead of militias you know
sargon of akkad says
i can pay 5000 men to do nothing other
than to drill in the arts of war and
then i'm going to send them out to
conquer the neighboring city-states and
there you have empire
the bible which is the source of our
our image our conception of a world of
of independent nations that are not
constantly trying to conquer one another
the sort the source of that is the bible
and the the uh the biblical world is is
one in which
uh
israel and and and and various other
small nations are are trying to create
to to to to fight for their independence
against
world empires against empires babylonian
assyrian persian egyptian which aspired
to rule the world my my claim is
fundamentally
twofold it's it it it's moral
that whenever you conquer a foreign
nation you're murdering and you're
stealing you're you're destroying you as
your own would say
you're using force to to to
to to cause people to submit so so
there is something in uh in in the
prophets that rebels against this uh
ongoing atrocity and carnage of trying
to take over the whole world
and um and and there's a a prudential
practical argument which is that the
world is governed best
when there are multiple nations when
when they're free to experiment and
chart their own courses that means they
they they have their their own route to
god they have their own
uh moralities they have their own forms
of economy and government and what tends
to happen in history is that when
something is successful when something
looks like when people a different
nation looks at and say well those
people are they're flourishing they're
succeeding then it's it's imitated and
you know in in the way that you know the
dutch invented the stock market and and
the english said look that makes them
them powerful so so we'll we'll adopt it
so that there's endless examples of that
so that's the argument for it the
argument is is um since since we don't
know
a priori deductively from self-evident
principles what is best
it it's best to have a world in which
people are trying different things so a
quick question because the word
nationalism sometimes is presented in a
negative light in connection to
uh the nationalism of nazi germany for
example
so
so you're looking empirically
at a world of nations that respect each
other i use the word nationalism the way
that i inherited it in my tradition yes
which is it's a principled standpoint
that says that the world is governed
best
when
many nations are able to be independent
and charge their own course that's
nationals as far as the nazis hitler is
an imperialist he hated nation states
his whole theory if you pick up uh i i
don't recommend doing this but if you if
you do actually reading here right now
mind conf right if you do read mineconf
then you'll see that he says explicitly
that the goal is for germany to be uh uh
the the lord of the earth and mistress
of the globe and he detests the idea of
the independent nation state because he
sees it as weak and effete he might as
well said it's jewish
you